welcome to this video I'm playing
Kamchatka from Russia let's see I could
play the Italian game for a change
go through one of the slow lines with d3
yeah I recently saw this idea with a
quick Bishop g5 under castles has been
played too numerous times by Grandmaster
chief Yakov at one point I probably need
to play Bishop III
I it's just returning to a7 this is
interesting it's a bit strange to
combine a6 with Bishop e7 but ok
okay so should I just exchange I wonder
about Bishop g3 if he goes d6 now I
think I can take a five okay and after
that I have the edge from I'll open very
hard to comprehend what he's doing now
if I if I can just to take a five okay
so let's do that
okay Queen takes I guess to control to
control with d5 I don't d6 I have 96 if
everything else fails I wonder if I
should play that move however yeah okay
let's get one of the bishops because of
the spin this move is possible
okay trying to take taking on b7 is
going route piayed would be - i don't
want that so just return yeah now he's
trying for some counter play but he can
play maybe f4 know if I Castle I mean
just f4 it could be some sub play not
sure that it should be enough but it's
it's a play I don't think I have any
particular auto it's just taking I don't
don't guess any movement I thought f4
would be a more interesting to try maybe
I can just take it after a phone and
play f3 or something I don't know but
this looks nice no it's just opening up
the position
this is better we end ok if he takes
Queen takes is very good
so should I'm John maybe H OS undertake
at some point ok after you take if it
takes knight takes Bishop c4 can be can
be a problem
yeah original intention i def 3 is not
particularly great he just gets the pawn
back okay so on this is this is a pawn
of course easy to count but not
especially easy to win
yeah the main issue is of course that
he's got this really good Bishop which
makes life um difficult for me how to to
play that may be here neide f12 III this
would help the night on b3 is just a
very bad piece as usual lights on b3f we
very rarely a good a good piece don't
I'm not current remember I was said that
tirage I think Tara [ __ ] was the squad
nights on b3 are always bad pieces or
something like that could have been
Stein it's not sure one of those guys
from the yeah 1900 1900 glue and 1800
something to 1900 something okay okay
it's a long all that that's let's go
ahead its Knight d5 move I don't think
Chang probably not
don't get her another spawn maybe you
should play a three no I have Quincy
wanna Quincy one and just give it a just
winning the porn problem
okay so Queen to e5 would be helpful
the knight only three is really nicely
placed it's it's very stable on the
square and it always protects the
sensitivity to square surprising
surprised that he puts this on c5 okay
I thought Knight f5 now was my idea I
can take
go here and take okay the time the time
Queen b8 was winning maybe I get a
second chance this is so winning as
before but still very good time warning
check
fortunately my king is completely safe
yeah that's a shame I need to settle for
Jack no I don't need to sell for draw
Jack this I can play with relatively
little risk
check check check check check
Joe it's close but it's enough black
resigns oh yeah I or as I so often I got
myself into big trouble
epic luck came yeah I had this this
extra pawn but it's it wasn't it wasn't
especially great around here I probably
made some technical technical mistake
not sure it turned into a very difficult
task
maybe night sir Knight f3 is maybe a
good news yeah maybe maybe something
like that intending to to get it to
deform if he takes Queen takes it's it's
a poops its opinion and I have maybe 95
coming yeah maybe something like that it
got really difficult the way I plated to
it was it was really little with the
night on this stupid be three square
getting the night to III was was a good
idea this I think I got me distinct
advantage again I might have five is a
good move him didn't think about that
with this idea that I missed that I was
so glad to get get rid of from Jesus
that I didn't look for for anything else
and he can centralize and improve I
think this is also good and here maybe
not a five immediately I don't I applied
this okay
adhere I missed Queen b8 I was just
eager to improve further but just this
is a simple winner King f7 and catch a
Kia and ninety six wins back the Queen
so a little tactic yeah this would have
been much easier at the end it was tough
with no time on the clock
alright thanks for watching